i've been uh sort of predicting warning
uh
you guys everybody i've been talking to
that the next two years
are going to be particularly insane for
two reasons
uh really three reasons one uh
a large part of the country and even
many of our elected officials
wrongly believe that the president uh
joe biden will be illegitimate that
the election was really won by donald
trump but joe biden stole it that
radicalizes people number two
right-wing media is going to be crazier
than ever uh fox news now not radical
enough
but fear not newsmax and oan and some
other
online uh platforms and outlets
are amping up the crazy and they will be
going absolutely no holds barred nuts
during the next two years and number
three we actually have
q anon type conspiracy theorists who
have been elected to the house of
representatives
we have absolutely nutty republicans
that
if you this this is not praise of like a
mitt romney republican but if you put a
mitt romney republican next to some of
these people
uh it's hard to imagine how they're even
um part of the same party at all
and i have a perfect example for you
that blends
in on craziness with radical right-wing
media
and it is a story about the new brand
new
q anon congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene
who has announced an impeachment of joe
biden now you might be saying wait a
second joe biden's not even president
yet
what impeaching joe biden what are you
talking about yes
and kooky congresswoman marjorie taylor
green
announced it on newsmax where else it's
too crazy
for fox news so she went on newsmax and
she starts stammering
because even she doesn't fully seem to
understand
why she's going to try to impeach joe
biden take a look
well and yes 10 or so republicans did
this as well we'll have more on that in
a bit
congresswoman i understand though you
have something uh pressing something
important and something new you'd like
to share with everybody
yes i i would like to announce on behalf
of the american people
we have to make sure that our leaders
are held accountable
we cannot have a president of the united
states that is willing to abuse the
power
of the office of the presidency and be
easily bought off
by foreign governments uh foreign
chinese or chinese energy companies
ukrainian energy companies so on january
21st
i will be filing articles of impeachment
on joe biden wow
articles of impeachment on joe biden on
his first
full day as president as funny
as her idiotic explanation is
the newsmax hosts greg kelly's reaction
when she's sort of like
pretending this is huge breaking news
but in reality she's she's just a a
lunatic radical right winger speaking
nonsense
him having to pretend like this is wow
very very powerful
is part of what makes that clip just
unbelievable now she may well be telling
the truth
that she's going to draft impeachment
articles
against joseph r biden jr on january 21
2021 just seven days from today
what's nuts is we've been talking about
are republicans going to impeach joe
biden just for the hell of it
and apparently at least this one
republican is going to
it will go nowhere because democrats
control the house
and democrats control the senate and
most importantly because joe biden
hasn't done anything worthy of
impeachment of course and
if you needed and this is an early
signal
that yes these people are going to be
just as crazy as they were
during their pre-elected official lives
and yes
right-wing media is going to be levels
of crazy that we only previously
uh uh sort of skated by with fox news
take the craziest thing that's ever
happened on fox news
that's going to be 24 7 on newsmax and
that's going to be 24 7 on oan so
there's going to be no shortage of
insanity
to debunk over the next two years um and
just a few other
we're going to talk about the metal
detectors at the house of
representatives on the bonus show today
so i don't want to say too much about it
but we now have a house of
representatives
increasingly riddled with
outrageous conspiracy theorists and
radicals marjorie taylor green
the woman in the video we just played a
guy named
madison cawthorne they've admitted that
they carry firearms he admitted that he
carries
firearms with him onto the house floor
multiple firearms he's
in a wheelchair and he says the
wheelchair allows him to actually have
multiple firearms with him
marjorie taylor greene saying she
legally has guns so why shouldn't
she be able to have them on the floor of
the house of representatives
and now metal detectors are going in to
try to stop that so these are really
scary outrageous people who are now
in the house of representatives and
there's two ways that this could go um
the the optimistic path is that the
election of people like
marjorie taylor green and madison
cawthorne and others
is a blip that remember members of the
house are up for re-election
every two years they're constantly the
their campaigns for reelection are going
to start in seven or eight months
already
the hope would be they did in their
particular districts
very trumpy districts uh ride the wave
of trumpism to the house of
representatives and that they'll be gone
in two years that's the optimistic
side the more pessimistic side and the
scarier side
is that although donald trump will be
gone we talked about how his
impact will continue through the judges
and supreme court justices that he
selected
this may also be the legacy of trump
people like these folks
who may remain in the house and there
may be this wacky q anon trumpian
contingent that remains in the house for
some time
it's very scary and we almost
immediately i mean listen they'll start
campaigning in seven months we'll start
dealing with it in seven eight months as
well
but we're gonna have to activate to make
sure that these people are just one term
members of congress and we'll have
plenty of time to talk about that
this episode is sponsored by bluechew
one of the things i make a priority on
the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda approved
ingredient
as in viagra and cialis it can be taken
day or night even on a full stomach
since it's chewable
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed
doctors you don't have to go to a
doctor's office you don't have to wait
in line at a pharmacy it ships right to
your door in a discreet package
they're made in the usa and since blue
chew prepares and ships direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all
no more awkwardness we've got a special
deal for our viewers and listeners go to
bluetooth.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our promo code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n
just five dollars shipping that's blue
chew.com
promo code pacman to try it totally free
bluechu is the better cheaper faster
choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
david pakman show